[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوين
سلطه المدنيه
[تصفيق]
موجه جديده من التظاهرات والاضرابات في
ايران والحرس الثوري يهدد المحتاجين لن
نرحمكم
القوات البحريه السعوديه تضم الاسطورها
احدث السفن القتاليه ضمن مشروع السروات
في الرابعه
وزاره العدل والصحه في السعوديه تعلناني
نقل اختصاصات الهيئه الصحيه الشرعيه الى
القضاء العام
ولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان يعلن
تطوير جزيره سندان اولى اولى الوجهات
البحريه في نيويورك
وقعت القوه السياسيه السودانيه على
الاتفاق الايطاليه الذي يهدف الى حل
الجمود السياسيه في البلاد حضر التوقيع
ممثلون عن الاتحادين الافريقي والاوروبي
والامم المتحده والاليات الثلاثيه واللجنه
الرباعيه منصه بنود الاتفاق الايطاليه على
تنظيم انتخابات في نهايه الفتره
الانتقاليه المحدده بعامين والتي تبدا منذ
لحظه تعيين رئيس الوزراء واشارت ابرز
البنود الى الاتفاق على شخصيه شخصيه مدنيه
شرفيه لرئاسه الدوله كما نصر اتفاق
الايطاليه سودانيه على التاكيد على الجيش
وان يكون رئيس الدوله القائد العام للجيش
ومن ابرز بنود الاتفاق الايطاليه السوداني
اطلاق عمليه شامله لكشف الجرائم
ومحاسبه مرتكبها
هذا ورحبا رئيس الجبهه الثوريه الهادي
ادريس بالتوقيع على الاتفاق الايطالي
واصفا اياه بالحدث العظيم
في طريق السودان
ويشكل
فتحا جديدا
لمستقبل السودان
نحو التحول الديمقراطي
المنشود
بشان مواقف الدول الحاضره في مراسم توقيع
الاتفاق لطريق قال السفير الامريكي في
السودان جون غودري في كلمه نيابه عن
الاليه رباعيه والتريكه قال ان الاتفاق
الايطاليه يبقى مفتوحا وان اطرافه يرحبون
بانضمام اي اطراف جديده داعيا الى تشكيل
حكومه سودانيه المدنيه لحل قضايا البلاد
العالي
[موسيقى]
وهي خطوه الاولى نحو اقامه حكومه سودانيه
سياديه لفتره الانتقاليات تنتهي
بالانتخابات
تشكيل حكومه مدنيه هو امر ضروري ولذلك
ندعوه في تشكيل حكومه سودانيه مدنيه لحل
قضايا البلاد العالقه نعمل مع الشركاء
لتقديم الدعم الاقتصادي للحكومه الجديده
لمواجهه التحديات التي تقف عائ امام الشعب
السوداني كما نرحب بايه اطراف سودانيه
ترغب بالتوقيع على الاتفاق لطاري مستقبلا
قبل التوقيع على الاتفاق النهائي
بدوره قال ممثل الامم المتحده في السودان
فولكس ان التوقيع على الاتفاق الايطالي
يلبيت تطلعات الشعب السوداني معتبرا ان
العمليه التي ادت الى هذا الاتفاق كانت
مملوكه للسودانيين وقيادتهم
بين الاطراف المهنيه للتواصل الى حل
الازمه السياسيه في البلاد كل ذلك من اجل
اعاده النظام الدستوري بما يتماشى مع
مطالب الشعب الهادفه لاصلاح المدني وذهاب
نحو اجراء الانتخابات وترسيخ قيم
الديمقراطيه هذا الالتزام نحو التحول
المدني بمثابه عمليه ادت الى هذا الاتفاق
كانت مملوكه للسودانيين وقيادتهم اننا
نعمل ان تترجم بنود الاتفاق لافعال بشكل
سريع واحترام الحقوق والحريات بغض النظر
عن خلفياته السياسيه والعرقيه والدينيه
في ملف الاحتجاجات في ايران لقيت دعوات
الاضراب والاحتجاج دعما واسعا داخليا
وخارجيا وقد كده المقرر الخاص للامم
المتحده المعني بحقوق الانسان في ايران
جاويد رحمن للشعب الايراني انا المجتمع
الدوليه معهم مطالبا اياهم بالحفاظ على
المعنويات فيما راى نجل شاه ايران سابق
رضا بهلوي
خلق ملحمه بالابتكار في اساليب المقاومه
تنسيق احتجاجات عمال عقود النفط بايران من
جهته لانه لا توجد طريقه اخرى سوى النضال
الموحد للدف للدفاع عن حياه الايراني وكان
المجلس التنسيقي لنقابات المعلمين
الايرانيين اصدر بيانا يدعموا الاحتجاجات
والاضرابات العامه المرتقبه
في المقابله فادت وكاله تسنيم الايرانيه
للانباء ان الحرس الثوري الايراني قال ان
القوات الامن لن ترحم من وصفتهم بمديري
الشباب وقطاع الطرق والارهابيين كما اشاد
الحرس الثوري بالقضاء الايراني لموقفه من
الاحتجاجات وحذفه على الاصراع في اصدار
الاحكام بحق المتهمين بارتكاب ما وصفه
الحرس الثوري بالجرائم ضد امن الوطن
والاسلام
رابع مستمر
لاقرار اتفاقيه مكه لاجهزه انفاذ قانون
مكافحه الفساد
اهلا بكم جدا اهلا بكم من جديد في جده
غربيه السعوديه انطلقت اليوم اعمال
الاجتماع التحضيري لاقرار اتفاقيه مكه
المكرمه لاجهزه انفاذ القانوني مكافحه
الفساد في دول منظمه التعاون الاسلاميه
وذكر الامين العام لمنظمه العالم الاسلامي
حسين ابراهيم طه ان هذا الصرح القانوني
سيشكل لبنه جديده في البناء المؤسسات
والقاعديني المنظومه القانونيه لمنظمه
التعاون الاسلامي مما سيساهم في الحد من
التاثيرات السلبيه لظاهره الفساد على
المجتمعات الاسلاميه التي تقود التنميه
وتهدد امن الدول وتعرقل جهود التنميه
المستدامه حول العالم
في اسبانيا القوات البحريه السعوديه سفينه
جلاله الملك حائل من تراث كورفت افندي
2200 لتكون السفينه الثالثه بعد تدشين
سفينتي جلاله الملك الجبيل وجلاله الملكه
الدرعيه وتعد السفينه احدى سفن مشروع
السروات الذي يشمل تصنيعه وبناء خمس قطع
بحريه بقدرات النوعيه للتعامل مع مختلف
المهام القتاليه بقدره وكفاءه عاليه
بالاضافه الى مساهمه في رفع مستوى
الجاهزيه البحريه وتعزيز الامن البحري في
المنطقه وحمايه المصالح الاستراتيجيه
الحيويه السعوديه
في السعوديه اعلنت وزاره العدل والصحه
اكتمال انتقال اختصاصات الهيئات الصحيه
الشرعيه من وزاره الصحه الى القضاء العام
وذلك بعد توقيع مذكره التفاهم التنفيذيه
بين كلا الجانبين وزاره العدل اوضحتنا
القضاء العام سيباشر تلك الاختصاصات بشكل
كامل تفعيلا لاليه العمل التنفيذيه لنظام
القضاء لنقل اختصاصات اللجان شبه القضائيه
التي تنظر في قضايا الجزائيه او منازعات
تجاريه او مدنيه الى القضاء العامه فيما
بينت وزاره الصحه ان مذكره التفاهم ستسهم
في سرعه الانجاز للبيت في القضايا ومنها
الاخطاء الطبيه
من الرياضه المشرق العام على محفظه القضاء
في هذه الشريم حياك الله يا استاذ فهد
خليني ابدا معك من
ما اهميه نقل اختصاصات الهيئات الصحيه
الشرعيه الى القضاء العام وما هي
الاختصاصات التي
ستتعامل معها المحاكم بعد هذا القرار حياك
الله استاذ خالد في البدايه راح احبك
وارحب بالساده المشاهدين بكل خير كانت
هناك رغبه مشتركه بين الوزارتين في دراسه
اختصاص النظر في الدعوه الناشئه عن
الاخطاء الطبيه صدرت توجيهات معالي وزير
العدل ومعالي وزير الصحه في ذلك الحين
بتشكيل فريق عمل يقوم بدراسه هذا الموضوع
والعمل على اعداد وثيقه نقل الاختصاص من
وزاره الصحه الى وزاره العدل بعد اعتماد
هذه الوثيقه تم تشكيل فريق عمل من
الجانبين يقوم باليه التنفيذ بلا شك ان
اليوم همم احد اهم الاهداف او في مجموعه
من الاهداف الاستراتيجيه المفترض تنظرها
همم من هذه الاهداف همم تقليل امجد
التقاضي عن طريق سرعه البث في القضايا رفع
جوده الخدمات المقدما للمستفيدين تحسين
تجربه المستفيد تطوير منظومه القضاء
المتخصص والاختصاصات التي ستتعامل معها
هذه الدوائر تنظر الى ثلاثه اختصاصات
الاختصاص الاول الاخطاء الطبيه المتعلقه
همم بالديه او الحق او عفوا او تعويض همم
الاختصاص الثاني الاخطاء الطبيه التي ينتج
عنها وفاه لا سمح الله او تلف عضو من
الجسد او فقد من فعلته بالاضافه الى
الاختصاص الثالث النظر في مسؤوليه
المؤسسات الصحيه الخاصه همم التي يرفع بها
مطالبه بالحق العام او الخاص الان كيف يتم
تقديم همم خطا طبي مثلا هل هناك ايضا
اجراءات معينه واجبه قبل الرفع هذه همم في
البدايه تنظر همم المؤسسه الصحيه في
الشكوى المقدمه من قبل الشاكي او المستفيد
همم اذا لم يحضر او اذا لم يتم تسويه ترفع
الى وزاره العدل بعد اكتمال متطلبات صحيفه
الدعوه يعني الخطوه الاولى ست تكون في
وزاره الصحه ما فيها سينظر في في الخطا
الطبي بعد ذلك يرفع التقرير الطبي اذا لم
يحدث تسويه بين ااه بين طرف الدعوه ترفع
الى وزاره العدل للنظر فيها
بالنسبه للقضايا همم يعني الموجوده حاليا
ربما لتتعامل مع علي الصحيه الشرعيه في
بعض القضايا صلى سنوات
الطبيه الصحيه الشرعيه بوزاره الصحه التي
لم تنظر همم ستنقل الى الدوائر همم في
القضاء العام لدى وزاره العدل بعد اكتمال
المتطلبات الخاصه
صحيفه الدعوه ما هي هذه المتطلبات الخاصه
اكتمال الملف الطبي
ويعني ممكن من اهم المتطلبات اللي هي
اكتمال الملف الطبي وراي الخبره في في
الخطا الذي حصل ااا لماذا لا يتم التوجه
مباشره الى الى المحاكم بعد هذا القرار
بعد ان تم نقل اختصاصات هذه الهيئه الصحيه
الى القضاء العام بدل من الذهاب الى الى
وزاره الصحه او الايات الصحيه الشرعيه
طبعا من المتطلبات لابد ان اليوم يحقق من
الجهه ابتداء في الاخطاء بعد ذلك ترفع
الجهه راي الخبره الموجود حاليا ثم تنتقل
الى وزاره العدل متى سيتم البدء بالعمل في
في هذا القرار بدا التفعيل منذ يوم امس من
اعلان التدشين في اربع ديسمبر 20 22 الى
اي مدى مثل هذا القرار ممكن ان يعالج بعض
الاشكاليات المتعلقه بالمساله
التعامل مع الاخطاء الطبيه بعض الاشك
متعلقه بالتاء بالتاخر ربما الهيئات
الصحيه في البث بقرارات معينه في ما يتعلق
او باحكام طبعا نقل الاختصاص اا يعني زي
ما ذكرت لك اليوم من ضمن الاهداف في نقل
الاختصاص سيعالج سرعه البث في القضايا
بالاضافه الى معرفه المسؤوليه الطبيه او
الصحيه التي حدثت من قبل خلينا نقول
المشتكي او حتى كان ال- ال- ال- همم
الكادر الصحي شكرا جزيلا لك المشرف العام
على محفظه القضاء فهاد الشريف
كشف المركز الوطني للارصاد عن توقعات تشير
الى فرصه هطول امطار رعديه من متوسطه الى
غزيره على عدد من المناطق في البلاد قد
تؤدي الى جريان السيول على اجزاء من تلك
المناطق تقرير ذاكره ان هناك احتماليه
لتكون الضباب خلال الليل وساعات الصباح
الباكر علاء اجزاء من مناطق الشرقيه
الحدود الشماليه الجوف تبوك المدينه
المنوره وكذلك مرتفعات مكه المكرمه
من جده ينضم الينا محل الطقس في المركز
الوطني للارصاد عقيل العقيل حياك الله معي
سيد عقيل الان هذه التوقعات كيف يمكن
النظر اليها الحاله المطريه المتوقعه في
مناطق المملكه واين تحديدا
اهلا وسهلا استاذ خالد بالفعل المركز
الوطني للارصاد اصدر توقعات وتقرير مفصرا
حاله جويه بدات يوم امس الاحد خاصه في
ساعه المساء اليوم تاثرت المناطق الشماليه
الشرقيه في حفر الباطن ومجاورها بهطول
الامطار نتوقع ان شاء الله تعالى مع تقدم
ساعات المساء يتاثر طول القطاع الشرقي
المدن الساحليه الشرقيه بالسحب الركابي
الرعديه وهطول الامطار ولا يستبعد ان شاء
الله تتاثر منطقه القصيم خاصه الاجزاء
الشرقيه منها ومنطقه الرياضه المحافظات
الشماليه كالمجمعه الغلط الزلفي شقره وما
جاوره هذه المناطق همم ومن المتوقع ان
تتاثر كذلك الحال العاصمه الرياض من بعض
تشكيلات من السحب الركاميه الرعديه
بالاضافه الى سلسله الجبليه المملكه
مرتفعه جازان الشرقيه مرتفعات منطقه عسير
والباحه وكذلك على السواحل منطقه مكه
المكرمه وشرق مكه المكرمه كل هذه الحاله
ان شاء الله الجويه متوقع هطول الامطار
عليها على وكذلك الحاله جاء منطقه المدينه
المنوره ان شاء الله تعالى حجمها هذه
الامطار المتوقعه
هل لديكم معلومات ربما
نعم هو اكثر غزاره الامطار متوقعه على
اقصى المناطق الشماليه الشرقيه ستكون
امطار متوسطه الى غزيره اخذت تؤدي الى
الجيران الاوديه والسيول على بعضها اجزاء
منطقه القصيم خاصه الشرقيه منها الساحل
الشرقي ستكون امطار متوسطه في مجملها قد
تكون غزيره احيانا كذلك الحال على بعض
المحافظات الشماليه منطقه الرياض ان شاء
الله تعالى في مثل هذه الحالات ما من
تتواصلون او الى من تصل توقعاتكم هذه من
الجهاد
جميل همم نحن لدينا نظام الي نظام مبكر
يشرف عليه متنبيين جويل مداومين على مدار
24 ساعه في اليوم يتم ارسال التنبيهات
لدينا اول شيء ثلاث تنبيهات تنبيه باللون
الاصفر وتنبيه متقدم باللون البرتقالي
والتحذير باللون الاحمر يتم ارسال معظم
هذه التنبيهات الى اكثر من 500 جهه حكوميه
واهليه مباشره حينما يصدر المتنبي الجوده
يتم ارسال هذه الجهات همم في ثواني معدوده
لجميع الجهات همم المعنيه بهذه الحالات
الجويه عن طريق نظام اوتوماتيكي كذلك
الحاله تواصل مع جميع الجهات الحكوميه عن
طريق ضباط الاتصال او عن طريق غرف الطوارئ
المتواجده في بعض امارات المناطق وهذه
الامطار المتوقعه ستكون في اي مستوى من
مستويات هذه التنبيه
طبعا هناك تحليل الي لرفع التنبؤات لرفع
التنبيه في البدايه يبدا التنبيه باللون
الاصفر ثم تنبيه متقدم التنبيه المتقدم
يجري عليه كما يجري على تنبيه باللون
الاحمر من احتمال السوق واخذ الحيطه
والحذر لجميع المواطنين حينما يتم رفع
التنبيه او رفع درجه التنبيه الى من
البرتقالي الى اللون الاحمر بالتحذير يقوم
المتنبي الجوي بمتابعه الحاله الجويه انيا
عن طريق صور الاقمار الصناعيه عن طريق صور
رادارات دوبلر في المملكه بالمناسبه
المملكه مغطاه ب 95% من مساحتها عن طريق
رادارات دوبلر وهذه الرادارات تعطينا دقه
في حركه السحابه واتجاهها وكميه هطول
الامطار والتوقعات فيها الاستاذ هذه
الامطار يعني هل تاتي في اطار الحاله
الطبيعيه المطريه التي تمر المملكه سنويا
ام انه في تغير في هذه الحاله ربما مع
حاله التغير المناخي التي يعيشها العالم
بشكل عام
نعم الحقيقه امطار المملكه تنقسم الى
قسمين امطار صيفيه وهذا متواجد في الجنوب
اكثر شيء على مرتفعات وامطار ربيعيه
وشتويه وهذا ما تؤثر به اجواء المملكه في
المناطق الوسطى والشرقيه والسواحل الغربيه
وهذا مع امتداد منخفض البحر الاحمر كذلك
الحال مع امتداد المنخفضات الحركيه في
البحر الابيض المتوسط تبدا هذه المنخفضات
في فصل الشتاء خاصه وهذا ما تشهده اجواء
المملكه من هطول الامطار بسبب حركه
المنخفضات كذلك بسبب تقابل الكتله الهواء
سواء الدافئه الرطبه القادمه من الجنوب او
الشماليه والشماليه الغربيه البارده تصادم
هذه الكتل الهوائيه هي التي تؤدي الى
حالات عدم الاستقلال يعني اقصد انه هذه
الحالات المطريه وتوقعاتكم خلال فتره
القادمه هي تبقى في الاطار الطبيعي ولا ان
هناك تغيرات ربما في الحاله المناخيه
المتوقعه خلال الفتره القادمه
احيانا الاستاذ خالد يحصل هناك حالات شاذه
وحالات متطرفه من الطقس النماذج العدديه
طويله مدى والتوقعات المناخيه طويله المدى
لا تتنبى بمثل هذه الحالات الجويه
المتطرفه ولكن التقرير الذي اصدرناه لفصل
الشتاء لي خلال هذا العام نتوقع ان يكون
معدل هطول الامطار اعلى من السنوات
السابقه هل هو مرتبط بتغير مناخيه او لا
هذا
يكون عبر دراسه تحليليه اكثر ولسنوات قد
تمتدي الى عقود لمعرفه مدى التغير المناخي
على الجزيره العربيه اشكرك شكرا جزيلا
عقيل عقيل محلل الطقس في المركز الوطني
للارصاد جدا
يقعدوا في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض منتدى
الاعلام العربي الصيني بمشاركه عدد كبير
من المسؤولين الاعلاميين من الصين والدول
العربيه
بين الاطراف المختلفه الى مستوى الجيد بما
يعزز من التواصل العميق والروابط ايضا بين
الحضارات والثقافتين العربيه والصيني
شكاوي عديده من اصحاب المحل بسوق الاسماك
الجديد في القطيف بينها انتشار العماله
المخالفه
من صلاحيات رئيس الوزراء ويؤسسه لسلطه
المدني
موجه جديده من التظاهرات في ايران والحرس
الثوري يهدد المحتجين لنرحمه
القوات البحريه السعوديه تضم الاسطورها
احدث السفن القتاليه ضمن مشروع السروات
وزاره العدل والصحه في السعوديه تعلناني
نقل اختصاصات الهيئه الصحيه الشرعيه الى
القضاء العام
وولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان يعلن
تطوير جزيره سنداله اولى الوجهات البحريه
في
اهلا بكم من جديد همم نذهب مباشره الى مقر
عقد المنتدى الاعلامي العربي الصيني من
الرياض ينضم الينا وفد العربيه احمد بجاتو
احمد مرحبا بك ما هي اجواء هذا المنتدى ما
الذي يتطرق اليه ايضا في موضوعاته
يعني كما تشاهد من خلف مازالت اعمال
المنتدى العربيه
من الشخصيات الهامه سواء كان حضوره بتواجد
داخل هذه القاعه او حضوره افتراديا تحدث
عدد من المسؤول المسؤولين الصينيين وكذلك
المسؤولين في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
واتحاد اذاعات الدول العربيه المنتدى خرج
بعدد من المبادرات الهامه ابرازها بالطبع
همم مبادره تعزيز التعاون بين وسائل
الاعلام العربيه والصينيه وهذه المبادره
تنبع واهميتها من انها تركز على تعزيز
التفاهم وتعميق الروابط بين همم الشعوب
العربيه والشعب الصيني كذلك حمايه مصداقيه
الخبر وتبادل الخبرات ما بين وسائل
الاعلام العربيه والصينيه ايضا هناك اعلان
عن اطلاق برنامج بث مرئي بالتعاون مع هيئه
الاذاعه والتلفزيون السعوديه وكذلك
ااا مجموعه الصين الاعلام كذلك سيكون هناك
عرض
لمجموعه من الاعمال المرئيه عام الصينيه
على وسائل الاعلام العربيه وهذا امر جديد
يعزز من التفاهم والشراكه بين همم الدول
العربيه وما بين الصين هناك ايضا تاكيد من
قبل يعني بعض المسؤولين السعوديه التي
تحدثوا منهم وزير الاعلام المكلفه الدكتور
ماجد القصبي همم التاكيد على ان هناك عدد
من الاعمال سيتم اعضاء في وسائل الاعلام
السعوديه وكذلك العربيه تعني ادعى
الكاميرا تتحرك خالد همم يعني لتوضح بعض
الحضور في هذا المكان كما تشاهد هناك ندوه
تديرها احدى الاعلاميات الصينيات همم
مجموعه تصوير الاعلام بالتعاون مع تحدي
الدول العربيه وكذلك همم وزاره الاعلام
السعوديه همم تهدف الى الارتقاء بالشراكه
الاعلاميه ايضا
تعزيز التعاون والتعاون والتواصل وتعميق
الروابط بين الحضاره الثقافيه والثقافه
العربيه والصينيه همم هناك همم يعني تحدث
بعض الحضور عن ان اكثر من 60 عاما
العلاقات ما بين الدول العربيه وكذلك
الصين هذا الامر يستدعي مزيد من الارتقاء
في الجانب الاعلامي لان الجانب العلمي
عليه مسؤوليه كبيره في تعزيز الروابط بين
الشعوب في هذا العالم المليء بالاخبار
وهمم المغلطات لذلك هناك تاكيد من قبل
المسؤولين سواء كانوا مسؤولين العرب او
مسؤولين من مجموعه الاعلام همم مجموعه
الصين للاعلام في ان يكون لوسائل الاعلام
دور هام في تصحيح بعض المفاهيم الخاطئه
همم حمايه مصداقيه الخبر في كلى همم سواء
كان في الصين او في الدول العربيه وكما
ذكرت لك هذه المبادرات التي خرجت تعزيز
التعاون والتواصل بين وسائل مختلفه وكذلك
اعمال مرئيه ستعرض ولاول مره بصوره مستمره
همم على وسائل اعلام العربيه وايضا هناك
بث برنامج مشترك ما بين الصين وما بين ما
بين هيئه الاذاعه والتلفزيون السعوديه هذا
هذه الامور كلها تؤكد على ان قادم الايام
بالنسبه الى علاقات الصينيه العربيه ستكون
مختلفه ستهدف الى تعزيز التعاون المشترك
بين الشعوب العربيه وبين الشعب الصيني
وزياده للفهم يعني التعامل والترابط بين
الشعبين شكرا لك احمد همم
ندوه الصين والعالم العربي من الرياض
توصل الجهات المعنيه في مكه المكرمه اعمال
تطوير المشاعر المقدسه التي تتضمن تطوير
المخيمات الحجاج وغيرها من الخدمات التي
يتم العمل عليها لخدمه ضيوف الرحمن
القادمين الى المشاعر المقدسه ذلك بعد ان
تفقد مسؤول وزاره الحج والعمره مواقع
منشات خدمه حجه جدا
لتطوير المخيمات وابرز التحديات لخطه
السير وموقف الحافلات بمشاعري عرفات
ومزدلفه رموشات خدمه حجاج الداخل غير
المشموله بخدمه قطار المشاعر
شكاوي عديده عبر عنها اصحاب المحال في سوق
السمك الجديد في محافظه القطيف حيث يعاني
السوق من بعض الاهمال والمشاكل الفنيه في
البنيه التحتيه بالاضافه الى سيطره
العماله المخالفه على بعض نشاطاتهم
العربيه تواصلت مع بلديه محافظه القطيف
للظهور في التقرير والرد على هذه الشكوى
ولكنها لم تتجاوب الزميل عبد الرحمن العصي
رغم افتتاحه قبل اشهر قليله الا ان
الشكاوي بدات بظهور حول سوق الاسماك
الجديد في القطيف اصحاب المحل التجاريه
والصيد الاسماك ابدا للعربيه استيائهم من
عدمي تجاوب امانه المنطقه الشرقيه وبلديه
القطيف مع ملاحظاتهم حول البنيه التحتيه
في السوق الجديد الى جانب انتشار العماله
غير النظاميه وسيطرتهم على حراج الاسماك
خارج اوقاته الرسميه سوق القديم كان سوق
قوي سبب انه موجود حواليه الخضار اللحم
الدجاج المطاعم المواد الغذائيه يعني
حوالي محلات متكامله اغلب الزباين اللي
تيجي السوق هنا كانت تشتكي من قله الخدمات
الموجوده غير جارين بيصير الخدمات وده ما
في
بعد ما نسوي يعني خدمات هذا حتى الصراف ما
عطلنا هنا طلع انت العالم واحد لو احتاج
اغراض اكياس ما اكياس محل خدمات ادوات صيد
المفروض يخدم المنطقه مطاعم عندك
شيء
الامير احمد بن فهد بن سلمان زار قبل اكثر
من شهر سوق الاسماك الجديد حيث استمع الى
شكاوى المواطنين بحضور امين المنطقه
الشرقيه المهندس فهد الجبير واحدا اياهم
بحل مشكلاتهم في القريب العاجل جزيره
الاسماك في القطيف تعتبر من ابرز المشاريع
الحيويه في المحافظه تكليفه انشائها بلغت
80,000,000 ريال سعودي بمساحه وصلت الى
حوالي
120,000 متر مربع سوق الاسماك يعد من ابرز
مرافقه هذه الجزيره في مساحه تبلغ سته
الاف متر مربع عبد الرحمن العصيمي من
محافظه القطيف العربيه
الى الرياض مع محمد الجنه
[موسيقى]
خالد اخبار رياضيه حياكم الله تخطى
المنتخب الانجليزي عقبه السنغال نحو دوري
الربع النهائي بفوز عليه بثلاثه اهداف من
دون رد ليضرب موعد مع المنتخب الفرنسي في
مباراه مثيره مرت مرتبه هدف الانجليزي
الاول عبر لاعب الوسط هينجرسون الثامن
والثلاثين من عمر الشوط الاول يحتفل بهدفه
الاول في كاس العالم قبل ان يفك اخيرا
هاري كينز
ويسجل هدفه الشخصيه الاول في هذه المسابقه
والثاني لمنتخب بلاده في هذه المباراه عند
الخامسه والاربعين ومنحبك يسارك منتخب
بلاده الهدف الثالث عند الدقيقه الثامنه
والخمسين يؤكد حقيقيه المنتخب الانجليزي
بالوصول الى دوري الثمانيه
[تصفيق]
تلاقي فرنسا التي قادها النجم كيلين ان
بابيل العبور الى ربع النهائي بعد ما سجل
هدفين في شباك بولندا في مباراه انتهت
بثلاثه اهداف من دون مقابل لصالح منتخب
بلاده ونجح بتسجيل الهدف الاول لمنتخب
فرنسا في الدقيقه الرابعه والاربعين والذي
اصبح به الهداف التاريخي لمنتخب البيوت 52
هدفا
متخطياريه
[تصفيق]
كان الاول وفي الدقيقه
هدفه الشخصيه الثاني عند الدقيقه 90 سجل
ليفاندوفسكي هدف بولندا الوحيد مره ركله
جزاء في دخله التاسع من الوقت المضاف على
المباراه
[تصفيق]
تسعد البرازيل اليوم لتجنب المفاجات عندما
تلتقي مع كوريا الجنوبيه كان منتخب
البرازيل تعرض لهزيمه مفاجاه امام
الكاميرون في الجوله الثالثه من دوري
المجموعات بينما تاهلت كوريا الى الادوار
الاقصائيه بعد تحقيقها فوزا مستحقا امام
البرتغال بهدفين مقابل هدف تعد هذه
المباراه الاولى بين المنتخبين في كاس
العالم
[موسيقى]
منتخب كوريا الجنوبيه يصل الى مرحله خروج
المغلوب للمره الثالثه بعد ست مشاركه 40
نقاط جماعه شمسنا الكوري واحتل بها وصافه
المجموعه الثامنه بفارق نقطتين عن منتخب
البرتغال
بعد خبر التاهل كانت الدموع هي الحدث
الابرز في كوريا كسب بها التعاطف الجماهير
صن الذي يضع على عاتقه حمل منتخب بلاده
تعدى مرحله كونه نجما في ملاعب واصبح رمزا
في كوريا والجماهير تنتظر منه التالق امام
السامبا تماما مثل ما يفعل في انجلترا
منتخب البرازيل هذه المره هو مرشح فوق
العاده لاضافه النجمه السادسه الى السادسه
لكن الهزيمه امام الكاميرون دقت ناقوس
الخطر في معسكر السامبا كتيبه تيتي وصلت
الى الادوار الاقصائيه وهي مثقله
بالاصابات
من البطوله وحاله من الشك تحوم حول جاهزيه
الظهيره الاساسيه
دانيلو والكس سانترو وتبقى الانباء التي
تتحدث عن جاهزيه نيمار هي النقطه المضيئه
في النفق المظلم فهل تتمكن كوريا من
استنساخ تجربه 2002 وتطيح باحد الكبار في
هذا الدور ام ستثبت البرازيل بانها قادمه
لتتويج بالكاس الثانيه لها في القاره
الصفراء
ويلتقي المنتخب اليابانيه امام نظيره
الكرواتي ضمن منافسات دوري السته عشر من
كاس العالم خلق الساموراي مفاجاه بتصدر
مجموعته امام منتخبات كبيره مثل اسبانيا
والمانيا بجانبي في عين وصيفه النسخه
الماضيه كرواتيا يسعى لمواصله مشواره
ببطوله بعد احتلاله المركز الثاني خلف
المنتخب المغرب في المجموعه السادسه
كل وصفاتها
التي يلتقي فيها وصيف بطل العالم المنتخب
الكرواتي بنظيره الياباني في تاريخ
النهائيات في فرنسا عام 98 كانت المواجهه
الاولى بين المنتخبين بدور المجموعات
وانتهت بهدف اليتيم لصالح رفاق دافور شوكر
قبل ان تتكرر بعد ثمان سنوات في المانيا
وبدوري المجموعات كذلك وانتهت بالتعادل
بلا اهداف
الموعد الثالث بين المنتخب
الماضيه واليابان في الدوري الاول بفوزين
على المانيا واسبانيا جعلها تصل الى ثمن
النهائي بمعنويه اكبر بحث عن انجاز
تاريخيه بعد ان خرجت منه في ثلاث نسخن
سابقه
كرواتيا بقياده مدربها ازالاتكو داليتشو
وخبره الثلاثي مودريتش وكرامه ريتش
وبيزيتش بلغت الثمن النهائي دون ان تقنع
في دوري المجموعات واليابان تالقت وابدعت
وخلفت كل التوقعات
الظهور القوي لسود الاطلس جذب اهتمام
الصحف الاسبانيه انجاز يتكرر للمره
الثانيه ولكن ليس من صداره المجموعه هل
يتغلب الاسود على انفسهم في هذه النسخه
المغرب يدخل دوره 16 للمره الثانيه في
تاريخه وبمعنويه عاليه بعد تصدر المجموعه
السادسه
[تصفيق]
ان المغرب يقف في تاريخ اسبانيا ووصفته
بكونه افضل جيل في تاريخ الكره المغربيه
ويعتبر المنتخب
لم يتفوق على اي منتخب في الاستحواذ على
الكره الا انه كان الاكثر تسديدا على
المرمى من منافسين
[موسيقى]
ويشهد معسكر المنتخب المغربي بعد الاصابات
ابرازه لاشرف حكيمي وعز الدين مناحي لكن
مشاركتهما امام العروخا والده
ويلقى وليد
لزملاء حكيم زياش وذلك رغم وصوله قبل
ثلاثه اشهر من انطلاق المونديال وهو الذي
اصبح اول مدرب عربي يقود منتخب بلاده لدور
16 في الارث العالمي
[موسيقى]
اخبار المونديال نعود الان الى الزميل
خالد
[موسيقى]
اهلا يا ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان عن تطوير جزيره سندان اولى وجهه
نيوم للسياحه البحريه الفاخره ونوادي
اليخوت على البحر الاحمر وذكر الامير محمد
بن سلمان ان المشروعه سيكون بوابه للسياحه
العالميه في البحر الاحمر والمنطقه وتقع
الجزيره على مساحه اجماليه تقارب 840 الف
متر مربع وتعد احدى الجزر التي يجري
تطويرها في اليوم وتضم جزيره سنداله عده
مزايا منها مرسى حيوان مع 86 رصيف البحرين
من المتوقع ان يستحديث المشروع ايضا
3500,000 وظيفه تدعم القطاع السياحي
وخدمات الضيافه والترفيه على ان تبدا
جزيره سندريلا في استقبال زوارها بدايه من
مطلع عام 2024
وفي شرق السعوديه يوصلوا مهرجان واحه
الاحساء الثقافي فعالياته الثقافيه بتنظيم
من هيئه التراث ومحافظه الاحسن المهرجان
يستمر على ماده 30 يوما في سته مواقع
تاريخيه وترفيهيه يعكس عراقه الاحساء
وعمقها التاريخي من خلال العديد من
الفعاليات الثقافيه والترفيهيه وفي عدد من
المواقع التراثيه وتاريخيه في الاحسن
المهرجان واحه الاحساء في الهفوف ينضم
الينا مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن
العصيمي هلا عبد الرحمن
الاجواء في المهرجان اول شيء كيف تصفون
نعم خالد كما يقول المثل الشهير الحسا
حاساك لو الدار نساك هذه المنطقه الجميله
القديمه العريقه في وسط الهفوف مليئه
بالحياه حقيقه واقبل كبير من العائلات
والاطفال وايضا المشجعين القادمين من قطر
لنا منفذ سلوى القادمين عن طريق البر من
الامارات او البحرين او حتى سلطنه عمان
لابد ان يدخلوا الى همم او يمر بمدينه
الاحساء ومنطقه الاحساء كما نشاهد وزع
زميلي المصور ياخذنا ان جوله هذا المهرجان
همم خالد في اكثر من قسم كما نشاهد هذا
قسم القهوه الخاص بهيئه التراث ايضا هناك
العاب خاصه للاطفال العاب القديمه
المتعلقه بالتراث السعودي ايضا الجميل في
المهرجان خالد انه يقع في وسط همم سوق
القيصريه في الاحساء هذا السوق اللي يمتد
عمره لاكثر
200 عام هذا السوق اللي تعرض لحريق كبير
عام 2001 وكان يعني حادث مؤلم لان هذه
الاحساء لكن بعد ذلك تم ترميمه اكثر من
مره ليصبح بهذا الشكل الجمالي هذا
المهرجان خالد ياتي بتنظيم من هيئه التراث
ومحافظه الاحساء بالاضافه الى امانه
الاحساء اكثر من جهه حكوميه مشاركه في
تنظيم هذا المهرجان هناك القهوه السعوديه
مسرح موسيقيين هناك عروض ثلاثيه الابعاد
ايضا الهدايا وكما نشاهد ايضا هناك مقاهي
ومطاعم جديده تم استحداثها في هذا المكان
الى جانب الجلسات المسائيه الجميله خاصه
خالد الان الاجواء يعني بدايه الشتاء في
الاحساس الجو في الليل ونسبه الهواء زي ما
يقولوا هل الحسا ترد الروح فالجاسات ايضا
جميله لكن الجميل خالد ايضا انه هناك
اقبال كبير من همم
السياح من مناطق او دول الخليج العربي
الامارات وقطر وايضا البحرين الانسان
الاحساء خالد هي تعتبر يعني سوق رئيسي
للتمور وايضا البهارات ايضا السمسم
الحساوي بعض الخضار والفواكه الرز الحساوي
هذا يجعلها ايضا يعني مركز تجاره مهم في
منطقه الخليج ايضا البشوت وبعض الحرف
اليدويه فكثير من اهالي منطقه الخليج يجون
هنا ياخذون ويتبضعون البضائع اللي ما هي
موجوده عندهم في مناطقهم الى جانب ايضا
الاستمتاع بالاجواء همم التراثيه ايضا
المدرسه الاميريه ليست بعيده عن القيصريه
تقريبا حوالي 50 متر ايضا تضم كثير من ورش
العمل وايضا المنطقه الحرفيين ودورات في
الخط العربي صناعه المنتجات الجبسيه
والجبصيه التي تتميز بها الحاسه كما نشاهد
ايضا هذه الجلسات
والطاولات الجميله والكراسي همم المختلفه
هذه ايضا
للمقاهي التي تم استحداثها والمطاعم من
خلال هذا المهرجان الذي يمتد لاكثر من
حوالي 28 يوم هو ايضا وضع هذا المهرجان
لايضا استقبال المشجعين مشجعي كاس العالم
القادمين من قطر اذا ارادوا ان ايضا
استمتع ويتعرف واكثر على ثقافه
الاحساء ومنطقه العفو فالجوه رائعه جدا
خالد وممتعه والناس شايف يعني مستمتعين
بالاجواء على قدر كبير حلو وشو ابرز
الفعاليات اللي ممكن تكون على هامش
المهرجان
هناك فعاليات موسيقيه وفنيه كثيره في
نهايه هذا الممر هناك مسرح خاصه
للفنانين ايضا هناك عروض للرخصات الشعبيه
غالبا تبدا بعد الساعه السابعه مساء
بتوقيت الاحساء حتى الساعه 10:00 مساء
هناك ايضا ورش عمل تتعلق بالفنون والحرف
اليدويه هناك عدد كبير ايضا من الشباب
المتطوعين من جامعه الملك فيصل في الاحساء
ايضا هناك انتعاش كبير تشهده الاحساء خالد
خلال الايام الماضيه فيما يتعلق النزول
الفندقيه وايضا المزارع همم انا يعني قبل
ما اجي الى القيصريه تغديت في بعض المطاعم
الشعبيه واتحدث مع الموظفين اكدوا بان
الحركه في الاحساء خلال الاسبوعين
الماضيين مع انطلاقه كاس العالم شهدت
ارتفاعا ملحوضا همم ايضا لا ننسى ان موسم
الاحساء خالد فعليا يبدا مع فصل الشتاء
همم مع الاجواء
لا ايضا هناك جبل القاره في الحسا ايضا
بحيره الاصفر ايضا همم قصر هجر
فاكثر من موقع تم تسجيله في يونسكو هنا في
الاحساء فلذلك هناك يعني تركيز كبير على
اهميه هذه المنطقه التاريخيه والاهتمام
بالمواقع التاريخيه من قبل هيئه التراث في
وزاره الثقافه بالتعاون طبعا مع امانه
الاحساء ومحافظه الاحساء جهات كلها يعني
تعاون متكامل لابراز ثقافه وتاريخ هذه
المنطقه هذه المهرجان عبد الرحمن ممكن جيد
الى حد ما يمكن فيها لكن المتوقع ان يشهد
يعني اقبال من الناس اكثر هل شفت ناس مثلا
قادمين رايحين على كاس العالم على الدوحه
حمراء في الحساسه مروه في المهرج
بالضبط حتى لو دخلت يا خالد للاحساء همم
يسارك يا عبد الله
يرضي الجميع طبعا يرضي جميع الاطراف
يعطيك العافيه
اشوفك اشوفك اليوم تدور هنا في السوق يعني
انجلش
والنصر كمان يستاهل
الكره ما ترى كثير يعني اذا راحوا مكان
يجيبوا الاخ وياهم واصدقائهم هدايا يعني
عساك منهم يعني هسه العدوه تنتقل ليلي
طيب شكرا لك يا عبد الرحمن
مهرجان واحد الاحساء في الهفوف
في موسم الرياضه 2022 يزداد التطور
والتحديثات على جميع الانشطه الترفيهيه
وقطاع المقاهي والمطعم
سار الصاعدي قررت اخذ المقهى لمستوى
الاكبر مواكبه لتطور الموسم لتنافس 1200
مشترك احدى اهم مسابقات وجائزه المطاعم
والمشروبات حصلت على المركز الاول في
التصميم الخاص في بوليفارد الرياضيه
[موسيقى]
لم يكن هذا المقهى مقهى المحليا
كانت تطمح مؤسسته ساره لان يصبح التراث
السعودي عالميا فشاركت في اهم جائزه لقطاع
المطاعم والمشروبات وتوجد طموحها بالمركز
الاول في التصميم هذا الفرع تحديدا
[موسيقى]
عند هدف وطموح انه احنا نبني براند سعودي
بمواصفات عالميه ونبرز تراثنا وثقافتنا
السعوديه للعالم ونطلع في من داخل المملكه
حريصين انه احنا همم نقدم على جائزه
عالميه مو جائزه محليه او جائزه على مستوى
الخليج فقط كان هدفنا انه احنا نبي جائزه
عالميه همم نوصل من خلالها تراثنا وثقتنا
للعالم
لم يكن التصميم السعودي وحده الذي يلفت
الزائرين للمقهى ويجذبهم لدخوله وانما
تواجدت نجد والجنوب ومناطق السعوديه
الاخرى على شكل النكهات يتلذذ بطعمها
الزوار ويتعرفون معها على عادات كل منطقه
بالرقصات والاهازيج المختلفه
حرصنا في فرع توكا موسم الرياض نحن نبرز
شيء جديد من العماره والتراث السعودي هي
العماره السلمانيه
فدمجنا بين التراث النجدي وبين
الحداثه والعصريه في التصميم همم
الموسم هذا اللي هو موسم الرياض 2022
برزنا شيء جديد بعد اللي هو العرضه
السعوديه المقهى الوحيد في البوليفارد
الذي يحتوي على جلسات الخارجيه يرحب ويودع
ضيوفه بالطبول وكلمات الترحيب المميزه عند
مختلفه في مناطق المملكه
من الرياض شهد المتروك العربيه
في بدايه الموسم
خلال السنه خالد سعد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نحن نتعامل مع موسم المربعانيه كبعث ثقافي
وبوعد مناخي فهي من الموروث واهالينا
يتعاملون مع موسم المربعانيه كبعت اقتصادي
وبعد حياتي فمع دخول موسم المربعانيه
يبدون يصدرون التمور المخزنه ومع دخولها
يبدون قصون اوراق وغصون الاشجار
للاستخدامات المتنوعه في البناء والاواني
المنزليه والعصي فقبل المربعانيه يكون
الماء موجود في غصون الاشجار وبعد
المربعانيه تغرق الاشجار وتكون خير صالحه
فقط تورق الاشجار بعد ذبولها ويخضروا ساق
النبتي وهو هشيم اذا ما اراد الله اتمام
حاجته اتتك على وشك وانت
مقيمه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فمع دخول مربعانيه الشتاء يتوقف الماء عن
الجريان في غصون الاشجار وقصها خلال هذه
الفتره يمنع التسوس ومع دخول مربعانيه
القيظ يكثر جريان الماء في غصون الاشجار
فتبدا تفرز ماده يميل لونها الى الاحمر او
الاصفر تستخدم للتطبب تسمى بالصمغ اشهرها
صمغ الطلح وخلال هذه الايام صياد العصي
يترقبون غصون الاشجار استعدادا لقصرها
حملته العصا للضعف اوجب حملها علي ولا اني
تحنيت من الكبر ولكني الزمت نفسي حملها
ليعلمها ان المقيمه
على سفر
[موسيقى]
الى العناوين
الاطراف السودانيات
يوسع من صلاحيات رئيس الوزراء ويؤسس لسلطه
المدنيه
موجه جديده من التظاهرات والاضرابات في
ايران والحرس الثوري يهدد المحتجين لن
نرحمكم
القوات البحريه السعوديه تضم لوصورها احدث
السفن القتاليه ضمن مشروع السروات
وزاره العدل والصحه في السعوديه تعلنان
نقل اختصاصات الهيئات الصحيه الشرعيه الى
القضاء العام
وللاحظ الامير محمد بن سلمان يعلن تطوير
جزيره سندريلا
شكرا متابعه لكم
[موسيقى]